in mind it took me half a year trying
different things
before i settle down what i want to do
during the process i contacted many
people for devices
and help including my friend so
um a friend uh who runs a mortgage
data company called embs and his name is
larry
so i asked him if he can give me
his data for me to try and he just
he generously said yes and that was a
big surprise to me
and i tried to load it
on different platforms but i really felt
at home working with market data
because it was something i have always
been doing
and liked and i have always been
good at so on january 1st 2016
i put together a team there were three
of us
myself and a neighbor who's staying at
home
to take care of her children and a young
man
freshly graduated from uiuc but couldn't
find a job
a friend of me send him to me and hope i
could train him
and boost his skills and improve his
chance in the job market
and he turned out um he ended up
working for me because he couldn't find
any other opportunities
i utilized my experience working for
hedge funds
and design a product that they could
possibly pay for
many things were new especially in terms
of technology
and the three of us have to figure out
many things
i was always calling friends for help
including
a few of them in this audience
i remember every week we seem to have we
had seemed to be stuck
by something that is quite impossible
then the next week the problem just to
magically
get resolved we pushed out our first
product recursion actually pretty soon
and then i realized i have to go out and
sell it
it was miserable i had absolutely no
sales experience i have always been on
the analytics
and also the buy side of the financial
market
i try to use my connections and i
visited different headphones
many people were very curious about what
we do
and it told me it is pretty cool but
nobody paid for it
they told me the bonds are so expensive
that they don't see how they can make
even one cent
more using our tools to justify
what they pay for unfortunately i was
introduced by embs to the federal
government
in the middle of 2016. they were facing
an inquiry from the congress a
particular situation
i went to washington dc to demo
my system it is not exactly what they
were looking for
but it's the closest thing they have
seen
so we started to provide monthly reports
to the government
agency to help them monitoring agency
mortgage market
they were very nice they told me oh we
have to pay you
and getting paid by the federal
government is not an easy thing
but they appreciated our work and in
2017
there are officially recursions the
first client
there could there could never be a
better client
uh first client like like that
uh this experience told me our timing
was just right even the original
market sector we were facing was wrong
so in march uh march 2017
we became amazon technology partner
hoping
having this hat would help us in
marketing our services
in the middle of 2017 we pushed out
another product called recursion
analyzer
a gui based tool for users to query
mortgage big data
a very early client helped us to spec
out
the requirements i had amazing clients
who trusted us
so much that they signed contracts
without
seeing the product itself they paid
and guided us to develop them
we also developed good relationships
with the media companies
we provide data to reporters
for their articles i became good friend
of
a few reporters i also got to know
my partner richard cost on linkedin
who originally tried very hard to write
articles
using our data he actually
was able to write an article and
published on bloomberg
and he made our names appear on
bloomberg
later on in the second half of 2018
i invited him to join us and
richard um is now the chief research
officer of
recursion and richard has a very
different background
um from mine he's an economist
and he look at a big picture all the
time
so that makes up my skill because i used
to look at
everything at a micro level at the
trading level
but he looks at uh the big picture
now we have survived five years it's a
pretty a big achievement as
statistics show only 10 of startups
survive the very first five years
uh so that's a pretty long uh
introduction for recreational history
let's move to the technology side
and in order to describe the relation
how we use the technology i have to
describe the data
first so we understand why um
the technology works uh well
with it so we started with
agency mortgage data agency mortgage
uh is a 7 trillion dollar
market and if you were familiar
with u.s gdp it's roughly
20 billion so agency mortgage data is
about 30 of the u.s gdp and
that what i'm talking about is the uh
residential mortgage only then there is
also
commercial mortgage agency commercial
mortgage which is
700 trillion dollars uh 700 billion
dollars
and that is twice as big as the
private labeled cmbs i
used to be a trading private label cmbs
for before i started uh recursion
so it's fairly big and the tables come
from our
data partner company embs is close to
a hundred and the biggest ones um
number of records is in terms of
billings
it is uh not extremely big data
but it's just big enough for relational
database to handle
and it is just big enough for
us to come in and create value
and plus our deep understanding of the
data
really helps
so and also uh i want to share a story
from last night
i was inviting a few friends to come and
join this event
some says oh great i will come and
some says sorry i will be very busy
and one friend actually told me i'm not
going to attend
because you are a amazon supporter
i was surprised and then i was pretty
amused
i thought that that was pretty
interesting and i asked
am i a really amazon supporter and
the answer is uh of course no but
i'm wondering if i take amazon out of
this title
instead of for 34 people in the audience
maybe i'll get 70 or 80.
so i'm gonna eat less is the only one
tool and um there are definitely other
big data tools
can achieve similar goal and i just
happen to pick amazon
and also i watch very carefully
on my aws bills every month
to make sure i'm not overcharged for
anything
so that means i am not a supporter
i'm a consumer technology is very
important
however what i cannot stress
enough is that even one
gets the right technology it doesn't
mean
you can deliver a great product it's
actually very
far from it what differentiates
recurring is our deep understanding of
the data
and the business that need the data i
have seen technology providers
try to solve all the problems by
upgrading hardwares
if querying speed is not satisfactoring
then add servers if data gets too big
then add disk space blindly doing this
will only end up with piles of
electronic garbage
and skyrocketing aws bills
now let's talk about technology
technology
and i want to hand it over
to my colleague piensu
she is the aws solution architect in our
in our firm and he didn't she didn't get
the title because
we give her the title she earned this
title by passing a very difficult
exam kenz and i also
met on linkedin i'm wondering if someone
is going to call me linkedin supporter
too
uh so hence welcome now it's yours
thank you lee um so
aws provides various cloud services
such as cloud computing and cloud
storage
it guarantees high availability of their
services by having different
service centers around the world another
advantage of aws services
is that they are quite flexible we can
skill up and down easily
based on our demand levels at recursion
we heavily used three services provided
by aws
we use rideshift as our database easy
tool for our computing work
and that's three for our storage
we provide big data solutions to our
clients
as a result a practical database is
essential to our success
in early stage we tried various database
products for example before aws
we tried more knight db anybody used
monet
before we found this really difficult to
use
the good thing about monet b is that is
an open source database management
system
and the bad thing is that it requires
some effort
to deal with the hardware issues and
conflict the environment
so pretty soon we give it up
another attempt is to use the dynamodb
a database product by amazon but this
database
is a k-vital database in another word
every record in this database can be
considered
as a map of attributes and values with
a primary key to retrieve it this
feature is more suitable for transaction
data
so after several tries of different
options
we finally settled with redshift
it's a database designed for big data
and complex analysis
we can create using sql language for
data retrieval
next
thank you russian handles well on
complicated analytical work by two means
firstly it is column oriented
by using this storage method it reduces
the
input and output requirements and the
amount of data
needed to be loading from this are
reduced
with that data loaded into memory we can
have more in-memory space
to execute queries secondly
redshift's design or massively parallel
processing
also contribute to the faster speed this
design automatically distributes
workloads
across multiple nodes in each cluster
and users can optimize the distribution
by choosing
appropriate distribution keys on the
table
the grid analytical ability of right
rideshift
ensures an excellent user experience for
our products
uh next live
in addition to the performance run shift
also provides flexible scalability
to match the capacity and the
performance needs
it can be easily adjusted to the aws
console
the most concerned issue of cloud-based
applications
is security amazon has a responsibility
model
to share the security responsibilities
between
amazon and its users basically amazon is
responsible for the security of the
cloud
and organization is responsible for the
security
in the cloud for example aws will take
care of the infrastructure of its
services
and users need to take responsibilities
related to its applications
besides we can control credentials and
access
by managing the identity and access
management accounts
you can also control access to your
cluster by setting up
a cluster security group for example
you can identify a range of ip addresses
and give them inbound access for
organizations that have a private cloud
vpc can be used to control access
inodes provides data encryptions as well
it can be enabled when creating the
cluster
and can and cannot be switched from
encrypted
to unencrypted directly also redshift
uses ssl encryption for data transition
to s3
so next we will talk about easy two
aws cc2 is one review
yeah um thank you so much this is great
so far we have a question in the chat
um if you don't mind me interrupting in
with with a question
uh sure okay yeah so so this person
acknowledges yeah sorry this is not
directly related to
to the main thread of your conversation
right now but could you share
um you know now or or maybe at the end
a little bit more about the solutions
architecture
solutions architect certification did
you take a class
before taking and passing the exam or
did you just work with aws
uh sure i can talk about now so
i do take a class before i take the exam
i took class on udaimy
and there is another uh organization
called wizard they also provide classes
about the certification
uh exams so i took the class there
uh and uh i also read some uh
resources provided by aws
on this certification exam
and after after learning uh like about
one month i took the exam
and passed it okay thank you
uh so uh we
we use aws easy to uh to build our
applications
so for example we built many interactive
front-end pages to help users query from
our database
users can get the data they need and do
not need to write any sql queries on
their end
aws offers a 99.9 percent availability
for each amazon ec2 region the compute
instances are located in wikic
which helps the user to control the
access ec2 has multiple instance tabs
instant storage and operating systems
that we can choose from
based on our needs at recursion we have
many different types of instances
used for various applications depending
on the workloads
and we can increase or decrease the
capacity easily in the aws console
however aws sets default limits on
resources which vary from region to
region
and the information regarding the
resources managed by easy tools
is also limited
another service we use is s3 s3 is an
object
storage service provided by amazon it
provides
a platform for us to transfer data to
the cloud
it's easy to manage data and control
access by setting up market policy
we can upload the data files to s3 and
then load it into our worksheet database
as i mentioned before
data are encrypted using ssl so
it's quite secured combining the
features of
aws services we set up daily and monthly
routines
to load data into our database
automatically
we reduced the tds and repeated data
cleaning and processing work
which improved both the efficiency and
accuracy of our data
besides we build up some automatic jobs
to provide customized applications
for our clients so next i will pass you
over to the
on our applications okay
so we actually built um a lot of
applications
uh agency actually right in the middle
is the application we built
um the very first application but it
wasn't
a great success we spent a lot of time
on it
then it hit the market and we didn't get
a lot of interest and then our second
product that gets sold
is uh uh the data cloud data cloud
is uh a copy of our database
so we actually uh make copies
of the database we are processed to our
clients
so the client can learn exactly the same
query as we do
actually my our client has better
service than us
so the same query can run a lot faster
than on our server depends on how much
they pay for it
um another uh service application we
have is the caller analyzer that is
running on our own um
redshift server it's a
it's a gui interface allow people to run
queries on big mortgage data
we did a lot of the value added um
steps by uh we
we qe uh we set up the query and
we already fixed all the possible
pitfalls
so in calculating loan level prepayment
speed
default speed on default rates
uh all those standards like s-curve uh
like hram know are extremely
easy using our interface and typically
in a traditional firm they will have to
have someone
do exactly the same thing and do a lot
of qa and it takes
a lot more time for them to achieve the
same results
last year we attended abs east
and we were having lunch on the same
table with a very senior
analyst from a big investment bank so we
compared
we're doing the same thing um thus
very junior analyst i i brought together
with me
she she was with us only four months and
she can do
the same query in five minutes a while
the very senior quant at the bank
it will take him to run overnight batch
to get the same result
and we also as i described
we compiled the mortgage derivative data
set
from agency market data and now even the
equity analyst
can make use of our data
and so the last uh
i want to talk about the v churning case
this is the user case that brought me to
washington dc
and brought the federal government as
our client
the situation is um there
are some servicers or issuers
refinancing the loans too fast and the
speed is
measured by something called cpr
and when in 2016 there is rarely
anybody that will calculate cpr
at long level it was at uh
uh a more aggregated level and
in that aggregated level it is uh
impossible to attribute the prepayment
speed
to individual companies and we solve
that
problem by calculating the same
statistics
at long levels so we can aggregate the
loans
um serviced by the same company together
and calculate that statistic called the
cpr
and then we can pick out which company
is prepaying the loans a lot faster than
its peers so
this is a timeline of we work with the
federal government
and the government to push out
policy and then we
provide feedback and monitoring reports
to them
and they push out additional policy
and eventually they took a lot of
actions and
put the situation under control this is
a
multi-year effort and here
are uh some charts to demo how it works
so the orange line refers one company
and the purple line refers to another
the orange line is one company and the
blue line
is another company the blue line is
actually is a very big bank
wells fargo and the purple line is a
non-bank company and um
you can see uh the purple line and the
orange
the deep orange line is a very high
this is a uh the preparedness
measurement called the cpr
it is so high that you can you can so
sure
that it's doing something that it
shouldn't be doing to reach that level
and but there is a lighter orange line
so the dark orange line is what happens
in
october 2016. that is a roughly
uh three months after i met um the
government
and started to provide monitoring so the
dark orange line is what i can report to
the government to what's going on so i
can
show them the chart with the dark orange
line and the dark
blue line and showing the difference of
the uh
prepayment speed of different companies
and the light orange line
and the light blue line is the same
measurements in uh 20
in april of 2017.
this is after the government to push out
a new policy
to slow down the prepayment speed and
you can clearly see
their policy is working because both
lines
went down even though the light orange
line is still a lot higher than the
the light blue line and from the bottom
bottom
is a time series from the whole period
of time
again it begins in october of 2016
that's
uh right after i visited them
and you can see how high the dark
orange line is and then in
april of 2017 and it matches
the light uh two lines uh at the above
chart
and you see the prepayment speed seems
to be
under control but due to the nature of
their policy
the previous speed actually picked up
again
so they uh the government has to uh
create new policies and after we work
uh for a couple of years you can see
this problem
is uh uh completely solved in the
beginning of
2018 because they took really harsh
penalty on those companies who violates
uh
the rules we provide um
we help them to qualify the procurement
speed
so they know when they go to tell the
company
stop the wrongdoing they can give them
the numbers that
we actually provide loan level support
for those numbers because
those companies are not happy when they
receive the speeding ticket
so this is uh the the first big
application
it's definitely not the only one
today uh i only have time for this one
uh we started a bit late
and uh i think we had a
very good talk so now we should start a
q a right
yeah thank you so much we already have a
question
um is it possible to see a demo of the
cohort
analyzer tool in the x-ray tool
oh definitely if you're interested i
don't think we have time to do it
here but if you are interested you can
send an email
to uh info at recursioncode.com
i can then we can definitely
uh accommodate
let me
how can i um
yeah i'm able to to type a response
could you say the
email address again recursion info
i nfo at recursioncode.com
encryption codec
and if you go to our website www
you will be able to find uh email
addresses
and also uh oh oh i forgot to
to tell every everybody we actually run
a blog
that is a very uh welcome
among the industry
veterans we don't have a lot of
followers because of what we talk is
very
niche not too many people understand
but this is part of our data
democratization effort is we push out
the similar content
comparable with those investment banks
will put their in
in their research but their research is
only limited to their clients which
means
most of the people wouldn't get access
to it but we make it
public so if you go to our website you
will be able to find the blog
and we have we actually market
those blog in linkedin also so you're
welcome to read our blog
great we have another question now are
you planning to expand
on other asset classes like cmbs
abs or clos uh
we definitely uh started working on
agency
cmbs already and number one reason
is that our data partner embs
can is processing this data we can get
data feed from them
number two reason is the market is
pretty significant
it's already 700 billion as i mentioned
is even bigger than private cnbs
number three reason is given what
happened
in 2020 the pandemic
make the multi-family uh sector
especially
interesting because um there's a lot of
dynamics
going on there and also there's a lot of
policy focusing
in this sector and for private
it's mainly because of the
access accessibility to the data
we are happy to work with other data
partners
and uh we just haven't talked to them
yet so i actually worked with
many different datasets before i treated
non-agency rmbs and at that time i
worked with corelogic loan performance
data and then later on i trade
cmbs privately cmbs i actually use um
trap and um intex
so i'm pretty familiar with those data
sets we just didn't establish
the relationship with the data vendor
yet
sounds good we have more questions
coming in
can you compare recursion versus
1010 data i might not have said that
right i'm way out of my depth
data data is uh uh i when i
work at paulson i actually use 1010 data
i
actually felt 1010 data is uh easy to
use because
i have a programming background it's not
a problem for me
but i do know it is pretty expensive
so when i quit and do my thing i did
keep keep ten-ten data in mind i think i
can provide a better solution
at a lower cost so it is a
a competitor uh of us and uh
uh they uh
we're different but we do compete in the
same battlefield
okay great a pair of questions
um any advice for someone interested in
starting a company with a focus on data
science
what felt like the biggest hurdle to
getting customers
uh so we actually last
year took a course sponsored
by the national science foundation
called icorp
and the the biggest thing
about starting uh a company is
to find your clients a lot of people
think if you can
find an investor then you're good but
really if you can find a client
you don't need your investor and even
you have your investor you still need to
find your client
so finding the client is the key
so uh that course actually trains
start-up founders
push them out of the door and talk to
your
potential market and we were told
day one all you have is a set of
hypotheses
you cannot assume anything you have to
validate your hypothesis
i think this matches my experience of
we pushed out our first product
agency x-ray and it wasn't a big success
then because of what i thought was not
right i
thought the hedge fund managers would be
willing to pay for it but
actually they don't it turned out the
cohort analyzer is a much better product
and they are willing to pay for it
but i didn't know i had the hypothesis
and fortunately
i was able to validate that and know
that doesn't work um very well early on
so i was able to
pivot and produce other things that
eventually
got us clients
great um next question
what are the greatest challenges and
insights to achieve the performance that
you achieved with redshift
is it possible to achieve sub second
performance with redshift
sub second ah i was saying credit shift
is really a great tool for big data and
big data do not mean to be very fast
i actually found out using redshift
carrying small dataset
could be very slow because it's not
built for small tables
so in addition to use redshift we also
use the trade uh
relational database because ironically
when the table is pretty small
and it's pretty slow and we when we
build
red shift when we build x-ray
it is a website and we want people to be
able to query
any bond interactively then using red
shift
running behind the server
behind the web server the respond
the responding time will be too slow and
i mean if the the query is big and
people will understand
when the query supposed to come back
fast and people
don't understand so we have actually
have to use dry shifter to pre-process
the data
and then see using overnight process
to push it into relational databases so
the website will work reasonably fast
great uh just to to stay on the same
topic for a moment
have you considered snowflake versus
redshift
uh i think this is definitely something
worth trying
but so since we already so deep uh
in redshift you know at this
moment we cannot afford to switch to
anything
else easily just like what i said in the
very beginning
it's just one tool and i believe there
are other solutions that will work
also but for now we
it doesn't make us to switch to
anything that could possibly work
because we are
already down that path and we already
pick a tool that works well
there's no good reason to switch to
another one makes sense
are you planning to offer
forward-looking prepayment
or default models uh great question i
actually get a lot of
such questions or or suggestions
i would say no because i know how
difficult building a model is i would
rather be the one that provided tools to
help other modelers
to build a better tool build a better
model
um it's just
it's just hard and also it's very hard
to prove
uh your model is good because
it tells something about the future how
do you know your model is good
for us we do everything we calculate
it can be validated by some something
else
given infinite time
you can always validate our numbers and
you will prove
that our numbers is right in a very
early stage
we push out the same number on agency x3
and
bloomberg actually is slower than us so
the next day people see the number on
bloomberg it's the same as ours
so it proves we are right and we are
faster
how do i do it for a model even
you know a model i i don't know i just
think it's too hard for us
and plus i think people want to
model too fast if there are things you
can know
you can know for sure you don't need a
model
so we are doing the part we there are
things we can tell you for sure
and after we exhausted all the facts
then people can build better model and i
think a lot of
time people just they don't want to
spend the time to dig out to the facts
and they just build a model
even something they can know 400
sure they they get a probability
distribution
uh i would rather spend the time
to to get higher level of certainty of
things we could know
coming from a cmbs background why did
you choose agency
rmbs as the first asset class
oh that is because that's the uh most
convenient
data set i could uh i could get access
to
as i described i got the data from
a friend we happened to be friend
because when i was
working for headphones the ceo
of the company approached my
my employee employers and he tried to
sell the data to my employers
so he was in touch with me we'll i will
never
i have never been trading agencies
agency rnbs so we never bought his data
but we became
friend and then he's the only one who's
willing to give me
his data and all the other companies
they're so big
even and call them i probably get no
luck so
and it turned out to be a very good
option
a very good choice because agency rmbs
is the biggest in terms of data set
among all the
things you were talking about and the
market has been growing
keep on growing in the past couple of
years
and also in terms of disclosure
it's uh exploding i started in 2015
and the biggest problem with the agency
mortgage
is the loan level disclosure and the
amount of data is
too much for people to handle so um
agencies were pushed to disclose loan
level data
after the financial crisis because
people realize
fannie and freddie are taking too much
risk and previously they think agency
mortgage is pretty safe
they are allowed to disclose um
poor level data only and then it all
changed after the financial crisis this
start
they took a couple of years for them to
get ready and
towards the end of 2013 they started to
all three agencies
were disclosing long level data and the
as of today there are 40 million loans
and only
2 million securities so that's
20 times the difference and then when i
started in 2015
and now it's 20 21 so it's
six years think about when i started
there was only two years of disclosure
and then now we have eight years of
closure
so the amount of data just quadrupled
and even more than that because the
agency insurance
also was humongous in the past couple of
years
so the growth of the data and the growth
of the disclosure really
helped our business in any other sector
if you you go to non-agency mbs
it's actually shrinking it's it's
shrinking
dramatically now there is nothing to
trade and also
18 and 19 cm yes almost the same thing
but agency mortgage agency residential
and
agency cms are growing
rapidly so even though i didn't choose
it
i really chose it because that's the
only option but it turned out to be a
a great choice cool
so this will be our last question what
are the greatest challenges
in data cleaning of the embs data set
in providing the database copy are there
any challenges helping clients
understand your database design um the
biggest
challenge is uh there is a lot of
unavoidable
manual work even though uh
we we tried to uh we tried a lot of uh
automation but there's still sometimes
you you do need to
have a person to look at it the good
thing is we
spend a lot of time to build such tools
then even
it's a manual process it can be done
by clicking and it took a lot of
designing thoughts of creating the tools
for ourselves to use
so we can do these things efficiently
and uh
incrementally so
our clients are our clients uh
uh our data cloud clients are really
very sophisticated
sophisticated clients so they would have
no problem
to start scratch to work they all have a
lot of experience with embs
so they're familiar with the data to
begin with
and also we because we do a lot of
research work
we provide we have a lot of simple
queries we can provide to them
and then they can also easily generate
sample queries from our system also it
really saves their time
and they appreciate they know if they do
this all on their own they will spend a
lot of time
to find out the outliers and figure out
how to how to so i was saying 80
of the time would be spent on catching
the last 5
of the strange things coming from the
data and it's all handled by us
and they can just use the query created
by us and they can
be confident that the query will return
something meaningful to them
that was our last question thank you so
much for your talk
and for answering all these questions
are there any um concluding remarks you
would like to give
um concluding remarks i i think
we're we're in a great position
as a recursion and uh we're really proud
of
what we do we think we bring value to
the whole financial industry
uh when i started this company i really
have something in mind
is i feel wall street
culture is about hiding because people
want to hide a piece of information
so it can be their advantage when they
do trading
they hope they can get a better price
because they know that a piece of
information
but the other side doesn't know about it
but i i appreciate better uh the silicon
valley culture
where people share and they
work on things collectively when i
started my company
i've been training for so many years and
i almost
don't have a lot of technology skills
left so i have to pick up everything
from scratch
i realized there are so many great
things you don't even need to pay
one cent for it for example the linux
operating system or for example the
version control
gets for example we tried
uh something called hiroku to deploy a
web services
and all this including python including
uh the the the sayings you talked about
the jupiter i think uh tense jupiter
all these open source software are
including
postgrads including mysql and uh
vim there is a
such long list i can name great things
you don't have to pay
and all these people around the world
work on it
collectively this is just amazing so
this is
what we want to do we want to bring the
transparency we want to provide
a affordable service to the smaller
players so they can actually gain an
edge even so they they don't have to be
taken
advantage of by the bigger companies
because they can do the same
if you subscribe to our cohort analyze
immediately
within five minutes you are like
my young analyst who can do a very
heavy task in five minutes you you
immediately beat
a senior account in the investment bank
that's what we are
what we do we are the disruptors and we
want to make
uh the financial market more transparent
that's so great thank you so much i'm
i've learned
so much i don't know anything about
finance so i personally have learned
a lot from this talk thank you so much
dr lee
and tiance for for joining us today this
uh concludes our january pi data chicago
meetup
please keep a lookout on our meetup page
for our february meetup
thanks everybody thank you thank you
bye-bye thank you
you